Traditionally, classic animation and visual effects production takes a waterfall approach
to creating content.
Generally that means that each siloed department produces a series of products that are published
for the next department to use in order to create their content.
This sets up a series of dependencies that limits a production speed based on the previous
department's output.
Think of it as an assembly line approach to creating content.
While these siloed departments are capable of working nonlinearly, it's difficult to
see the big picture without long waiting periods.
And what if a director wants major change?
The number of dependencies increases further down the waterfall.
The compounded time and effort required to make those changes becomes even more complex
when multiple software applications are needed to make the change.
The traditional pipeline usually contains these departments or silos.
Product development and pre-visualization, production design and look development, rough
and final layout, performance capture and animation, effects and simulations, cinematic
lighting, rendering, and editorial.
These departments still exist in a real-time pipeline, but now we must improve how they
work together, especially in a nonlinear workflow.
In this slide, we can see a typical animation studio flow chart.
It shows how data moves from one silo and its departments to another.
While this is a simplification of everything that is going on, it's fairly universal to
most pipelines.
So let's take a look at these one by one.
Number one, story development and editorial.
Here the story department creates a series of storyboards and scene descriptions that
feed the production design team.
They'll also work with the editorial and sound departments to produce a story reel from said
storyboards and feed those sequences as reference to the layout team for blocking and shot production.
Number two, production design and asset construction.
The production designer and his or her team of art directors and concept artists will
implement designs for various sets, props, characters, and other items for the film which
are handed off to the modeling team where they are built, rigged, surfaced, and put
into a scene assembly.
Number three, blocking.
Commonly known as rough and final layout, these teams are concerned with character blocking,
shot and sequence construction, integrating animation, and placing the camera.
Number four, performance.
Here we obtain either classic key frame or mocap performance capture to animate our characters.
Once shots are completed, they're sent back to the final layout team for camera refinement.
Number five, shot enhancement.
This is a collection of multiple departments that produce necessary image enhancements to
bring the shot to life.
Number six, image output.
Here lighting, rendering, and compositing are applied to shots to sweeten and finalize
their appearance.
And number seven, final editorial.
This is where all rendered shots are assembled into a cut with finalized audio and sound
effects.